can you imagine me wearing it like this
and going out on the road why what's
wrong I don't see what's wrong I'm
really excited about wearing saris I
have absolutely no idea how this works
didn't you also wanted to want to live I
did okay me neither
I'm going to do it in 30 seconds I think
that one was mine no wait it matches
with this color road this here is called
a petticoat is this supposed to go from
up or down because this is it this is
quite confusing they go before the sari
comes on this is going to make a lot of
people happy
this is really long is amazing man like
just look at all the color what are you
supposed to do with this bit I'm
supposed to pleat it yes you just have
to learn how to fold this I guess around
you okay so you basically wrap yourself
like a mummy I told you I was good at
this and now now it's simple now you
just do this I'm ready I'm not finding
anything wrong with this but I'm just
being told that this is not the right
what this I think this this is how you
do it right where did we go wrong I
think you'll need to start over okay
thank you do this again Lord
you decide how much of a value you want
I don't want to decide anything just as
we want to do is stop Gordon to watch
and learn you're going to eat this
it's this is man how do women manage one
up [ __ ] I have no clue why this was
riff only over one shoulder you know
what do I do with this now
suck it in ah like this pull it up
how am i crumpled in a table these are
elegant pleats any better open guys I
think this is my final form what do you
guys make of it huh yeah in all fairness
I can see how much effort women take
into getting ready how do you guys go to
pee like if you wear a saree do not do
hold yourself for like 12 oz I don't
know was that pleats thing is pop like
that is some messed up I'm no idea how
people do that that can't even be
mastered like that's an art within
itself every every woman looks beautiful
no no sorry this is the real way it's
supposed to have been won you were so
bad at it quite evidently man where do
women lost or their phones like yo Randy
ha ha no you have those pose such thing
is I really appreciate my mother a whole
lot more when she takes the effort to
wear a saree
oh nice I love you mom you're naked from
the front door do know I'm wearing a
blouse that's fine if you have only one